[Musique]
cet album est totalement expérimental le
résultat c'est que comme ci ou vol au
dessus d'un cabas qui se passe au loin
et où les plus tôt dans les nuages et
monte en les roulant au loin dit
du maloya le départ les assez simple vu
que c'est pour un film
il va sans faute à nous est assez
directif les connais que saliver et on
semble nous nous travail proche est à
chier pour arriver à ça avec ce petit
pas de côté là ma ville des directions
que mater prend pas et marion envie de
prendre ce chemin là le schéma la nuit'
c'est à dire aller vers des musiques qui
transporte et et qui fait le salvador le
flottement comme ça dans l'espace 5 me
fais là mais accessible et pas du genre
à part le fait que ces maloya dans un
mode électro laquait dja ou sliimy
expérimental il veut dire la musique
sera expérimental vous devrez pas
pouffer semblant miral toutes nos bonnes
machines mot bonne santé mozilla et là
ils savent à dans la musique où ça la
pointe de limite ou de carcans par
rapport il faut fait danser l'année puis
la cadence manu le malin avec le son et
salchaud
[Musique]